Break up suck
And there's no way around them other than going through the hoops
As painful as it is right now
We want you to know that it won't always be this way
Here are the 7 stages of heart break
1. Obsession for answers
We often yearn for closure
Because the confusion hurts too much
But closure doesn't always come
And more importantly
It doesn't change the outcome
You might be determined to gather answers from your ex partner's family, friends or co-workers
But eventually
Playing "detective" gets old
Which is why you move to stage 2
2. Denial
You might have stopped searching for clues and answers
But this doesn't mean you're ready to accept things just
yet
It's too much for you to process still
So, you're avoiding it for now
Hoping it's just a bad dream you'll wake up from
3. Sorrow
But no matter how hard you tried denying the truths
It eventually catches up to you
You start asking yourself
"Why me!"
And this time, you really let the water works out
4. Relapse
So, you finally managed to see the break up is really happening
But you're not ready to let them go
You tried to win them back, and come up with a million reasons "why they should still be with you"
5. Anger
But, it doesn't work
You feel fed up and angry about the situation
You start holding on to grudges
because it's better than not holding on to anything at all
6. Acceptance
But even then, you eventually grow tired of resenting your ex
So you try something healthier, by accepting the break up for what it is
You're not necessarily happy about it
But you're no longer bitter either
7. Hopefulness
Break up can leaves us feeling scarred and doubtful
But, the heart know how to mend over time
when you're ready
You start dating again, and see you past relationship as a lesson
it's important to remember that all the heart break you go through should be taken as an experience
Each one brings you one step closer to finding the perfect one
Are you going through a break up?
If so, which stage are you in?
Please share your thoughts with us below
For break up tips, check out our video here
Also, don't forget to subscribe to our channel for more helpful tips and share this video with others
With your help, we can reach more people and provide our supports
Thanks for watching